it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week there's the game coming
out with so much non-stop action it
could be a movie with Liam Neeson I will
look for you I will find you and I will
kill you its stride ered coming out on
the xbox one ps4 360 ps3 and even pc
that could be you riding that giant
robot dragon take out all the bad guys
and save the day februari 18 I was born
into slavery in Assassin's Creed freedom
cry adewale is an escaped slave looking
to gather a ship and crew so we can sail
about the Caribbean freeing his comrades
and serving Swift sweet piratey justice
to slaver traders and nothing really
says justice quite like a machete this
standalone game can be yours on the 18th
from the ps3 and ps4
also this week get to smash some bugs in
earth defense force 2025 it's the world
vs bugs in this third-person shooter and
after the events of the first invasion
of 2017 the nest have gained some new
creepy crawlies including a spider-like
creature which makes gigantic spider
webs and giant bees bees no keys bees
yeah start up your honey farm februari
18 this week Donkey Kong and his
sidekicks diddy kong dixie kong and
cranky kong are out to reclaim their
jungles that's been completely frozen
over and taken over by seals which as we
all know are the jerks of the sea
sausage I take you with ketchup start
filling up your Kong pal meter februari
21st and finally Rayman legends comes to
ps4 and xbox one and Snoop Dogg is
getting in on the action hopefully
they'll add a snoop dogg inspired level
like their eye of the tiger level come
on gangster which island in the big boss
dog yeah I had to do you start your next
gen Rayman adventure februari 18th for
further details is a game cross new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change
you next week to be a big one yep three
can't seeing double ope go GG